there's a whole world beneath the city
visited by over 4 million people each
day this urine scented metropolis is not
only home to pizza-stealing rats but one
of the most diverse music scenes in the
United States artists come from all over
the world to play on the stage when you
turn a corner or exit a train you never
know what kinds of sounds you'll be met
with sometimes it's classical violin
[Music]
sometimes it's EDM violin
[Music]
so we're here in New York City were
about to run around and interview a
bunch of street performers and the
season buskers I'm excited because I've
never performed on the street before
even though I've been performing and
playing the piano for about twenty years
now so we'll see what happens and maybe
they are on I will get a chance at
busting myself today ladies and
gentlemen my name is Dee hoof and I'm
here with a song for you
street performance often called busking
goes back to ancient times as author
Patricia J Campbell puts it there have
been street performers at least as long
as there have been streets just
day-to-day going through being on the
train walking through the city my wish
is always to be anonymous but this is
sort of the opposite of that here you're
putting yourself on the train that's
also good for performing but I think
it's different feeling like the reason I
think it I'm able to do this is because
I come and I bring a sincere energy and
how long have you been doing this done
this actually has my basically my day
job but like the last five years lost I
make better money doing this then I
certainly did waiting tables and
definitely then I did doing a lot of
other jobs that I only did for no reason
other than money so I mean hell I was do
I was doing this for free anyway
[Music]
I move to New York City to pursue my
dream of music but I was nannying
part-time I love kids and I was like
this is a good part-time job that all
allowed me to still like go to open mics
and like music and I would see people
busking and I always just thought it was
like so courageous and I'd see like of
G's in Wesker's for us it's like wow
like they're so talented and they were
so like carefree and I was just like I
wish I had those when I finally I was
like let me try it worked up the nerve
and I did it and I was making more than
I was anning so since then I just I
started by saying it
[Music]
here in New York City there's a
complicated legal history with Flushing
and over the last century the city has
gone back and forth on whether or not
it's allowed or banned during the Great
Depression busking became a popular way
to make money
that is until Mayor Fiorello LaGuardia
outlawed it in 1936 calling the street
performers beggars
[Music]
the band continued all the way to 1970
when poet Allen Ginsberg challenged the
ban as unconstitutional and won busking
is protected as a form of free speech in
the u.s. meaning it can't be prohibited
in areas where other forms of free
speech are not prohibited but even
though busking is now legal in the
subways that hasn't stopped the police
from arresting buskers cops are so
annoying even you know even that even I
have the permit they come up to me
sometimes like it's too loud or it was
really a struggle if you weren't a
sponsored musician if you weren't a
music under New York musician you go
through that process then yeah it was
tough
[Laughter]
[Music]
in 1985 the MTA created a program called
music under New York that gives artists
a special permit to perform in the
subways for some this permit is great
because it allows you to get priority at
popular locations and protection from
law enforcement yes so music under New
York is a program that was created for
people like myself and other talented
performers throughout the city to be
able to legally perform in the subway
and not you know get in trouble with the
police and so there are regulations like
there no spaces and pleasures you can do
it and things like that
the addition it takes once a year about
the addition maybe 300 people this year
and I'm 300 admittance into the program
is through one audition held every year
and from the over 300 musical acts that
applied in 2018 only 28 were admitted
this has led many musicians to criticize
the MTA for virtually controlling who
can and who can't perform in the subway
systems
muni is is maybe necessary in some ways
I suppose if you really want to not
break the law technically playing with I
kind of enjoy breaking the law the good
news is that in recent years the police
have begun to loosen up on arresting
buskers this is hopefully created a more
fair space where both Muni artists and
independent artists can share their
talents with the public yes absolutely
we've had mayoral changes so ever since
that leadership changed I've noticed the
law enforcement really loosen up on
busting buskers chops so to speak
[Music]
what motivates you to come out here even
on cold days like this it's soul food
for me it it's necessary for my health
or well-being
I like the comparison of busking to soul
food because it's the passion for music
that keeps these artists coming back to
perform busking isn't easy and even
though there are many rewards there are
just as many challenges
[Music]
my life
[Music]
what are some challenging things about
every now and then I get kind of a
Grinch like person how do you deal with
that
I don't I just people don't seem to care
anymore and everybody has headphones on
or they're looking at their iPhone you
know you're just talking at walls and a
lot of people do talk at walls in the
city a lot of people totally talk about
walls a lot of people are walls to be
talked at
[Music]
most challenging thing about busking is
getting things here yeah
lugging my step sound no electricity
playing with gloves on underneath a
great you know and the cold air just
like blasting down on getting those
sympathy tips at one point I was singing
and people were gathering and you know
applauding me and really getting into it
and singing along and putting money in
my little basket and this one person was
like I just see why do you have it loud
like you you know you sound terrible and
I was like okay I just I didn't really
react but she kept going in the morning
she kept saying crazy stuff the more
people would just put money in my basket
slow I was hoping she would keep going
[Music]
I also think that busting provides a
unique space to experiment what I mean
by that is when you perform at a concert
the audience is there to see you and
most likely came to hear music however
when you're busking you're performing
for people in their space and they can
choose to ignore you or stop and listen
you are imposing on people by being in a
place of open space and I mean you fart
on the train you're imposing on people
you know sorry I farted on your world
it's my idea of a nice smell
[Music]
do you feel like it's easier to connect
with people while you're busking versus
performing on a different stage or a
different venue I think because this
subway allows you to interact with
anyone at everyone and anyone everyone
can listen it gives you a wider platform
to engage with a wider audience as
opposed to someone that can afford to
pay or who's able to pay to go to a show
or whatever it is you know
you
I started busking because I known since
I was little that I wanted to be a
singer but as I got older and I was
auditioning and performing more I was
suffering from really bad performance
anxiety so much so that it actually was
getting in my way and I was using like
the joy that I had found in singing so
that's when I decided to do something
cold and like kind of like push my
comfort zone as best as I could and the
thing I thought it was singing in the
subway I deal with a lot of stage fright
and I have all my life
but any time I remember that it's about
something that's not within but outside
with the audience say it usually gets
better
[Music]
elimination
[Music]
I've questioned personally about busking
and playing outside publicly on the
keyboard I'm going to try it later on
today with my friend do you have any
tips for someone who is completely
immune to buffets
absolutely and someone who was rather
shy in terms of doing stuff in public I
do because I was there and actually I've
come a long way from when I started
busking it took me at least five years
to figure out that you have to interact
with the audience hey you guys ever
requests please write them on a $50 bill
you know stuff against people laughing I
mean you don't have to you can all be in
your instrument but it's a it's a huge
difference I see it in the tips and I
have a question about your van whoa sigh
yes a lot of people don't carry cash
anymore
right one day in the middle of a sad-ass
you know a girl came up to me she was
like oh do you Ben know and I was like I
know and she was like oh well I really
like what you're doing and I want to
give you a tip but I don't have any cash
so you should like get a memo and I was
like that is a fabulous idea yeah I
should get a memo
I met up with my friend Doulton and his
workspace in Soho he's performed all
over the world with his upright piano in
unexpected places like a subway car and
the Eiffel Tower hi my name is dotan and
today we're going to be we're playing
music in the subway so he's still like
around him I'm doing such a bad job of
this I'm sorry we just set up and we're
going to bus for about 20 to 30 minutes
and see what happens the goal is to make
[Laughter]
there you go
[Music]
and then you
[Music]
give us money nothing we need that up
the energy I mean part of it so I
contact maybe that looks good to me
in terms of engagement we got to be
louder the buskers that we met this week
made it look easy but in the end we made
just two dollars here in new york street
performers went from being called
beggars to an important part of the
subway experience and vital to the
city's music culture busking used to be
looked down upon the Lakotas hall hall
was for now and this time i think people
see bus me as oh wow he's doing an art
form it because bus comes in new york
are amazing i think it's important to
understand that what you're doing as a
busker is you are giving positive energy
to everyone that hears you and sometimes
you may have lift someone from a very
dark or negative place
nobody might tip you it can get
discouraging for sure that's an
indication that you're not doing it for
the right reasons
[Music]
if one day I was to look back at these
years as the best years of my life I'm
okay with it I'll be okay with it
[Music]
you